cuál es la importancia de esta disculpa
del papá francisco
creo que tiene una enorme importancia
debido a que sienta un precedente no
sólo en el caso de canadá sino en todo
el campo del sur global la acción de la
iglesia católica es asimilable en esas
mismas prácticas en toda américa latina
áfrica y asia y por lo tanto va a
generar también un precedente para la
acción y debe impulsar la iglesia
católica en todos los continentes en
relación a la reparación el
reconocimiento de responsabilidad
histórica y el cambio de actitud
respecto a prácticas que han sido de
asimilación forzosa y de destrucción
cultural bueno que sigue ahora en la
reparación a los pueblos indígenas no
sólo en canadá sino como usted lo estaba
mencionando pues en todos los
continentes
creo que lo que va a ocurrir primero es
una demanda por verdad histórica que es
lo primero que se debería instalar tal
cual
lo que ha ocurrido en canadá uno podría
decir que existen precedentes y
prácticas similares en el resto del
mundo sobre todo el mundo que ha sido
objeto de prácticas coloniales y la
relación entre la práctica colonial de
grandes potencias con la iglesia
católica donde ha actuado bajo el
criterio de la imposición la asignación
forzada y el etnocidio como concepto que
podría englobar la destrucción de un
pueblo y en segundo lugar vienen las
prácticas de reparación que van a
implicar
cambios también que pueden llevar
digamos a que la iglesia tenga que
entregar información a los tribunales y
finalmente reparar a las víctimas
directas